welcome back to Hannity sir president
Trump is continuing his call for tough
justice against that jihadis that
terrorized New York City killed eight on
Tuesday the president tweeted quote NYC
terrorist was happy as he has to hang
the ISIS flag in his hospital room he
killed eight innocent people badly
injured 12 he should get the death
penalty he then followed up with two
more tweets saying would love to send
the New York City terrorists to Gitmo
but statistically that process take
takes much longer than going through the
federal system there's also something
appropriate about keeping him in the
home of the horrible crime he committed
should move fast death penalty amen
joining us now reaction of the author of
defeating jihad former assistant to
president sebastio the president
sébastien corchia also from the Islamic
House of Wisdom Imam Muhammad Ali allahi
you think Iran is a good country don't
you Imam
so are you talking about New York or
about Iran now I'm asking you a question
you think Iran is a good country do you
not I know that somebody is fighting
Isis in the Middle East Iran simple
basic question just answer the question
do you think Iran is a good country do
you think there it's run by good people
Iran is a great country you're not a
nation a greater nation obviously you
know it's thousands of years of
civilization but let us talk about fear
mongering shun and division and
discrimination this kind of mentality we
have serious person is serious solution
and we have other gaps dr. korkor
they are one of the number one proxy war
funder exporter of terror in the entire
world and i know mom allahi
is speaking from his heart I've
interviewed him before he doesn't won't
condemn this how do we deal with their
export Gorka and their support of
radical Islamic terror shown when I came
into the White House I was brought in as
the strategist to the President to work
national security but specifically
counterterrorism and my focus had been
Sunni terrorism why because of September
the 11th al Qaeda Isis I have to admit
with the briefings I received with the
meetings we had in the sit room in the
NSC over a very short period of time I
realized that will crush the Sunni
extremists our Isis is on the ropes
we're stacking them like cordwood and
I've come to the conclusion shown that
the bigger threat to America is the Shia
jihadism of let me ask the Imam Imam is
it wrong the way Iran practice practices
Sharia law you know now you are talking
or sherry and Luke site prisons from is
talking about Sharia law when he's
talking about what about Joseph
Christian what about James Alex what
about Steven product you you never asked
me about this question just had eight
people slaughtered and the man said let
me finish and I'll send it to dr. Gorka
Allahu Akbar that's what he says we hear
all the time dr. Gorka right he shouted
God Allah is greater and we every single
attack of significance we see an
individual who says they're a Muslim
they're a jihadi we are not at war with
Islam but we are at war with people who
say I'm going to kill you because you're
an infidel that is the threat to learn
nothing wrong with Allah Akbar Shawn
there is nothing wrong that means God is
wise it happened in every terrorist
why do we hear it so often like on 911
and like this week there's eight dead
New Yorkers I live in New York I take it
personally
eight dead New Yorkers many more injured
why do we keep hearing it when there are
these terror attacks why why does the
country you support Iran talk about the
death of America and the death of Israel
and learn the American flag your problem
let me answer the problem is not with
God is great you believe God is great
don't you
dr. burka do you believe God is great
listen please
the problem is with those people who
don't follow God don't bother I'll leave
me like the originals give me like a
hostile regime that is Iran dr. korkor
with dr. Gorka okay let's be very clear
here we're talking about a regime that
is a theocracy that says religion
controls everything we're talking about
a regime that just now the Ayatollah
said that the United States is its
number one enemy this is a hostile
aggressive regime that is destabilizing
the whole rebonding terror for well
doctor dr. Gurkhas so many people are
you very much I know that you support
Israel and you are martyrs really than
yet Netanyahu but there are a lot of
people there are lot of people who say
that you are nasi and you justify the
genocide of Jews in Germany is that true
I mean there are lots of dr. Cordova
right let him talk
dr. Gorka citizenship because the Gorka
there are a lot of people who've said
very nasty things about me and the
president and i would be very very
concerned if the New York Post Politico
BuzzFeed CNN said nice things about me
because they're not interested in the
things that I'm interested when it comes
to the safety of the nation
we